et de l'autre côté dans le gouvernement
nous expliquer que les masques c'était
inutile dans la population alors qu'en
réalité c'est parce que nous avions une
pénurie de masques
il fallait plutôt dire nous avons une
pénurie de masques quand on nous dit le
confinement a duré 15 jours et donc on
sait très bien que à l'issue des deux
jours il a duré encore un peu de
plaintes a dit non ça y est les 15 jours
nous permet donc on en a peut-être
jusqu'au mois de mai et parce que c'est
compliqué je pense que les français ne
sont pas des enfants il faut pas les
infantiliser disons les choses
clairement
si on ne porte pas de masque c'est parce
qu'on en a pas si on fait pas de tête
c'est parce qu'on a là pas commander si
on est confiné
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que c'est la
seule solution c'est l'association carré
à ses solutions à des gestes barrières
il faut qu'on le soit durablement
continuer parce qu'on sait très bien que
dans quinze jours les choses il n'y a
pas de baguette magique avons pas se
restaurer moi je dis aujourd'hui que
cette crise du coronavirus c'est la
crise de l'anticipation
en attendant tire deux leçons l'actrice
de l'anticipation il faudrait pas qu'on
la vive à partir de nego l'hydroxyde
chloroquine dessus pour ça que ce que
disait laurent seillier tout à l'heure
si nous devons avoir des réserves
commençons à les faire maintenant et
attend donc que les études démontrent
effectivement l'efficacité de ce que
proposera août
mais ne soyons pas surpris une fois
qu'on aura décrété l'efficacité du fait
que nous n'aurons pas d'hypocrisie
dropsy chloroquine il faudra que je sois
là c'est pareil pour les tests et moi je
dis aujourd'hui qu'il va falloir quand
même qu'on utilise ces tests on sache si
on est porteur ou pas du virus si on est
immunisé ou pas c'est fondamental le
pays peut pas rester à l'arrêt
durablement
il va falloir m'ont donné qu on avance à
tulle et qu'on sache qu'il a eue qui est
immunisée qui peut repartir
éventuellement donc à la tâche pour que
le pays se remettre en mouvement donc là
aussi il faut que nous ayons une étape 2
dans le traitement de la crise il soit
celui de l'action on est en guerre faute
j'ai toutes les armes quand on est en
guerre et aujourd'hui faut pas qu'on
subit des mets un petit mot sur ce qui
se passe sur l'italie les courbes
française suit exactement celle de
l'italie et l'état lit a atteint le pic
et ce qui veut donc dire que nous nous
allons probablement aussi lui qu'on suit
les mêmes cours atteindre le pic d'ici
dix jours
ça veut dire que dans dix jours le
confinement ne pourra pas être levé car
si on atteint cela à l'heure du jugement
ça ne veut pas dire que l'épidémie est
finie ça veut dire que peut-être le pire
est passé mais on n'est pas sûr quelques
très certainement le confinement risque
de durer plus longtemps alors après je
ne sais pas est-ce qu'il est plutôt
préférable de dire aux gens vous allez
être confiné jusqu'au 1er juillet et
puis finalement 6 au 1er juin tout va
bien est ce que vous pensez que moi je
ne sais pas je pose vraiment la question
est ce qu'on est prêt à accepter
perspectives aussi loin alors que déjà
au bout de quinze jours n'en peut plus
et qu'on sait que bien des accidents
domestiques
il ya des gens qui n'en peuvent plus qu
il ya de plus en plus de définissent
tration je ne suis pas sûr que les gens
puissent entendre un confinement dans
trois mois ou jusqu'au 1er juillet
depuis quand les collages en train de le
4 mai le ministre de l'éducation
nationale nous explique que l'école pour
reprendre le 4 mai c'est pas sérieux
c'était avant et il est revenu là dessus
a priori ce ne sera pas le 4 mai
car il ne sera pas le 80 la reprise de
l'école louis laurent seillier moi je
pense que quelles sont elles aujourd'hui
ne peut comprendre que quand vous êtes
diagnostiqué comme 8,19 que vous n'avez
pas de facteurs qui vont contre un
traitement à la chloroquine que vous
n'êtes pas traitée à la chloroquine
personne ne peut le comprendre
on demande beaucoup d'efforts aux
français l'économie c'est le fond et
c'est normal parce qu'il faut qu'on soit
confiné et tout le monde fait un très
gros effort mais d'entendre qu'on
n'utilise pas un traitement qui existe
lorsqu'on n'a pas de facteur de risque
parce que la chloroquine on l'apprend
depuis des années des années les comptes
des oiseaux gazouillent cette science
hal est compris avec on cible je ne suis
personne ne peut l'expliquer mais ledru
en personne le dirigeant est vraiment
dites moi pourquoi on ne le fait pas
alors qu'on l'a on l'a dit depuis et
l'on dit depuis tout à l'heure alors en
sont d'ailleurs demandé à laurent
alexandre mais va vous faire là il va
vous faire la même reste que ce qu'il a
dit qu'il des besoins des personnes
âgées mais pour toutes les autres
personnes qui n'ont pas qu'ils font
c'est parce qu'il va il va gâcher vos
réponses ce qu'il a il a répondu il ya
un instant il a dit mais ce que
forcément il ya qu' il ya 98 % des gens
qui s'en sortent donc il y pourquoi
utiliser la chloroquine qui peut avoir
des effets secondaires sur des personnes
pour arrêter d'attaquer les effets
secondaires sont rares ça fait
des décennies que ce médicament qui
processeur ferrone je vous donnais juste
la réponse du docteur alexandre qui est
je pense que la nature à donner aux gens
qui sont hospitalisés des petits mots
dits responsables ne pas leur donner
parce que c'est vrai il meurt
aujourd'hui en france et 400 morts par
jour on sait que du rock secteur aux
kinks l'azithromycine diminue la
mortalité s'est démontré mon nom soit
arrêté je suis dis pas que ces
médicaments miracles
je ne comprends pas ce débat ce set
champions